We are currently in a crisis of leadership
so severe in the United States that Donald
Trump spent his weekend retweeting videos
of himself and threatening protesters with
vicious dogs and violence from Secret Service
agents rather than leading, uniting, doing
something productive because he doesn't know
how to do those things.
And according to one White House report, the
reason we've not heard from Donald Trump,
something from the Oval Office, a message
of unity, is that Trump has nothing to say.
So rather, he's staying quiet, except not
really because he's tweeting uncontrollably.
The U.S. is devolving into chaos.
Trump spent the weekend retweeting videos
of himself trying to take credit for the Space
X launch, threatening protesters with vicious
dogs, claiming he'll designate and Tifa a
terrorist organization.
He has no idea what to do.
It is a complete lack of leadership.
We fortunately heard from former President
Barack Obama with something that could be
approximating leadership.
We're going to look at a couple of items here,
starting with Donald Trump's threats to unleash
vicious dogs on protesters who might as well
have said we're going to get the fire hoses
out as well.
There have been varying levels of unrest around
the country stemming from the police killing
of George Floyd.
This includes people near the White House.
Trump tweeted on Saturday about protesters
near the White House.
Check this out.
This incredibly ludicrous rant. Trump saying,
quote, Great job last night at the White House
by the U.S. Secret Service.
They were not only totally professional, but
very cool.
I was inside, watched every move and couldn't
have felt more safe.
And they let the protesters scream and rant
as much as they wanted.
But whenever someone got too frisky or out
of line, they would quickly come down on them
hard.
Didn't know what hit them.
The front line was replaced with fresh agents
like magic.
Big crowd.
Professionally organized.
But nobody came close to breaching the fence.
If they had, they would have been greeted
with the most vicious dogs and ominous weapons
I have ever seen.
That's when people would have been really
badly hurt.
At least many Secret Service agents just waiting
for action.
We put the young ones on the front line, sir,
and they love it.
He might as well be saying Secret Service
is thirsty for blood and we're bringing out
the firehoses release the hounds is what he
is essentially saying here.
Now, this point about, you know, vicious dogs
and ominous weapons, that that's bad enough.
The idea that young Secret Service agents
are just waiting for action.
That's Trump admitting, claiming I'm guessing
the Secret Service would not even agree with
Trump's characterization.
This is Trump claiming that Secret Service
is looking to beat the crap out of people.
That's the opposite of leadership.
That's the opposite of bringing calm to a
nation that is dealing with essentially the
Spanish flu at the same time as some of the
worst civil unrest that we have seen, in addition
to a complete lack of federal leadership,
all combined at the same time, with a recession
slash depression going on, it's all happening
at once.
And Trump is doing nothing to actually bring
people together.
A real leader would ask for calm.
A real leader would go to the Oval Office
and address the nation, saying, we are a nation
in struggle.
I hear you.
I hear your concerns and your complaints.
I'm committed to working together to improve
the country.
Let's stop the violence.
Let's stop the attacks.
Stop the violence by police.
Let's realize that we are one nation currently
fighting a pandemic and a recession depression.
No one benefits from adding this chaos to
the pandemic.
I'm here with you on the inequality in our
justice system.
I'm here with you on policing.
Give me the space and the calm.
I need to work on this.
Instead, he tweets threats about vicious dogs,
read tweets himself, taking credit for the
rocket launch over the weekend.
That has nothing to do with him.
Says, Hey and TFA, you're now a terrorist
organization, which I will get to next.
This is incompetence combined with authoritarianism
from a wannabe dictator.
Donald Trump.
Don't for a second think that Donald Trump,
by the way, is not deep down planning to use
these protests to further disrupt the 2020
election for his benefit.
Unrest in major cities.
Things are way too crazy for vote by mail.
Ballots will be stolen or something.
We absolutely can't do it.
Trump has the power of the bully pulpit at
any point.
He could say, I'm going to use that for good.
He could do it.
Now, in so many ways, the country is plagued
by challenges, the pandemic, financial crisis,
oppression.
Rumination coming to a head.
And we have nothing from Trump.
He also tweeted, When the looting starts,
the shooting starts.
That's a quote from violent racist.
Miami police chief.
I forget his name years ago.
A tweet so hideous.
It was flagged by Twitter as glorifying violence.
A real leader would dial down the anger in
the heat.
Trump doesn't know how to do that.
So he's antagonizing protesters.
He's riling up his own base.
He's firing up the gun people.
And he's not even pretending to represent
all Americans here.
Trump opens his mouth and trash falls out.
That shouldn't surprise us anymore.
I hope people are realizing the urgent, urgent
nature of removing this president.
And we've got to keep our eye on the ball
because the distractions keep coming.
And that's what I want to talk about next.